the number one way to build a great
culture is to spend one-on-one time with
your employees and here's a key part of
the sentence make them feel safe to tell
you the truth of what's going well and
what's not and for you to figure out
what makes them tick here's how
everybody here me included who's
obsessed with what I'm about to say
everyone here wastes multiple hours
every day on dumb if you at your
level analyze your one-hour meetings
make a bunch of them 30. you've just
created two 15-minute slots to check in
and shoot the and really get to
know those 50. that tactic time
allocation to make them feel safe to
tell the truth you just want to make
them feel safe to tell you the truth of
what their Ambitions are what makes them
tick you have to be prepared for that to
change a 25 year old might want money
but a 32 7 years from now they might
want work life balance because they just
had their first child so that's the
framework you need to create